welcome to Python tutorials with simply
learn I'm Angela and today we look into
what tuples in Python are so let's begin
before we move ahead let's have a look
at everything that you learn today so
first we look at what exactly these
tuples are then we will see how you can
create tuples in various ways the
difference between tuples and lists
accessing the elements in a tupple the
operations done on tuples the built-in
functions with tuples converting the
lists into tuples then defining a tuple
inside a list and then we define lists
inside a tuple and finally we'll have a
small exercise so let's begin what our
top is a tuple is a collection of
immutable heterogeneous piping objects
so if you have gone through a previous
video on lists you would have noticed
that even list is a collection of
heterogeneous Python objects the only
difference between tuples and lists here
so the extra term that comes in case of
tuples are that they're immutable so
over here we have a tuple that's X and
within X we'll store various elements
189 a single letter M which is a string
also a word which is again a string in
Python habe o and B so as you can see
this tuple here may not be necessarily
completely filled with integers
completely filled with floats or strings
it can be a mixture of all of these data
elements so that is one advantage we
have when it comes to tuples and lists
as compared to a DS because with arrays
you can have only one data type elements
within it now we look at indices so
every element in a tupple takes up a
position and this position is what we
refer to as an index in plural that
indices so tuples positioning or the
indices for tuples and lists strings
also in case of Python and most of the
programming languages start with 0 so
your element 1 is at the 0th position
your element 89 is at the first position
and so on where B is at the first
position so in a way you can see that
the length of your topple X is 6 but
then the last index of your topple X is
5 because it starts from 0 onwards so
now that we have a basic idea
of what tupple is let's begin with
creating tuples creating tuples now the
first thing that we are going to do is
we create an empty tuple so say my empty
tuples name is EMP all you have to do to
create an empty tuple is give these
curved brackets with no elements inside
so this is a lot like lists but in case
of lists we had square brackets in this
case we have curved brackets so that's
the only difference now if I print the
type of EMP you'll see it's of class
double I can also print out just EMP and
since EMP is an empty tupple there's no
element within it but then of course the
black kids are still printed because
that's a list because that is the basic
characteristic of a tuple so even if
it's empty these brackets would still be
existing so we saw how to create empty
tuples but how often do we actually use
empty tuples so let's put some elements
into a tuple so let's start with
creating a couple with just one element
so say my tuples name is city and I'll
have one element Pune if you're creating
a tuple with one element if you're not
putting the bracket it's completely
valid as long as you have a comma after
that particular element so with this
kind of add syntax you can create a
tuple so I'll create a tuple say city
and I'll just have one element within
this which is Pune now if you are not
putting this element within these curved
brackets that's very characteristic to
tuples it's completely ok while creating
a tuple as long as you have a comma
after your element so although you have
no element after this comma that one
single comma is important so let me run
this and just type of city as you see
city has been stored as a tuple now in
the most standard way of creating tuples
you'll say City and within brackets
you'll pass your element also print out
city after that and the same syntax can
be used and then you can also combine
these both although that's completely
unnecessary effort but it's possible it
does not result in an error so you have
your bracket and the comma works just
fine now I want to add more elements to
city because clearly Pune is not the
only city we know so Pune Bangalore
these are some of the cities
in India if you are from another country
and wondering so after this demo you not
only know couples you also know a few
cities in another country so I have four
elements in the stubble and this is how
you create it all the elements separated
by commas and within brackets print out
city now I can do the same thing without
the brackets to just the commas indicate
that this is a topple now those are the
various ways you can create a tuple of
course all these ways do not come handy
usually you use this method to create a
tuple with n number of elements and when
it comes to one element you usually go
for this just put one element within the
brackets this is also used sometimes now
another thing we saw by learning what at
appleís or looking at the definition of
a tuple is the word immutable so we said
lists are mutable which means that they
can be changed and tuples are immutable
as and they cannot be changed so here we
will see a small example as toward the
difference between tuples and lists are
when it comes to the execution of these
both so say I have a list list one and
that has elements 1 2 3 4 and then I
have a tuple say tuple 1 which has the
same elements 1 2 3 and 4
now with list 1 I'll use this method
that you probably have encountered
before called append so I say list dot
append of 5 so what this function does
is it adds 5 at the end of this list
which is list 1 now we'll print out list
1 run this code and as you can see here
5 has been concatenated to our list 1
now let's try the very same thing in
tupple so tuple 1 dot append 5 and I'll
run this and see you get an error here
so the tupple object has no attribute
append in fact it has none of the
functions which you usually use with
lists because these functions aim at
changing the original list and not
giving back a new list in tuples case
you cannot change the original list once
your tupple is set that is how it's
going to be as long as it exists so that
is the main difference between lists and
tuples list is mutable whereas tuple is
immutable and other than that of course
you must have noticed these syntactic
different which is Liss our rit square
bracket and tuples may or may not use
parentheses or the curved bracket so
every time you print out a tuple or you
view a tuple it's always got those
brackets but as you saw while creating a
couple sometimes a comma is enough
so now let's access these elements in a
table if you want to print out the
entire tuple
we already saw just put it in a print
statement put the tupple list put the
tupple name in a print statement and
you'll have your table printed now if
you want to access some particular
element of the tupple say i want to take
out bangalore so in that case we use the
indices as we saw earlier in this is
start from zero and Bangalore is
therefore at the first position so I
have to just say city and within square
brackets one so this particular line or
the syntax is exactly the same as you
use for a list or string just run that
and here we go we have Bangalore now we
can also extract elements from the end
of the string just like we did in case
of lists so if I do not know the length
of the string now suppose I want to
access the very last element of my tuple
but I have no clue as to what the length
of my tuple is in that case what index
do I use well I can just go with minus
one now every time you give this minus
sign it starts accessing elements from
the end of the table so minus one means
the first element from the end of the
tupple which is Mumbai and that's what
we got as an output now although lists
are immutable there are a number of
operations you can still perform on them
for example the very first thing we look
at is concatenation so I already have my
tuple city will just print it out once
again here to see what it consists off
now we create another double same num
and this will have the elements one two
three four now sure I can't modify
tuples but I can definitely concatenate
these two so how do you do that
extremely simple city plus num the plus
sign works perfectly fine for
concatenation so I will print this out
and we have an error here that is
because we have not compiled our num
list first so our num list is not
existing right now I ran my line 19 now
I can run the next line we have one
complete list which has all the elements
of city followed by the elements of numb
now you can also nest up with status you
can have one tupple within another tuple
so so far we have a top with city and
numb now I will create another tuple so
first now we already have a tuple city
and numb what I'll do is I'll create a
new list say nest so this is going to be
a list so we have our brackets here so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a tuple within another tuple so
we have a new tuple I'll call it nest
and since this is a tuple the basic
syntax
I'll have the brackets now what will be
the elements within this the elements
would be my other two tuples which are
city and numb so I put in both my
elements here and let's see what nest
contains now so nest is a tuple which
itself contains of other tuples which
are city and numb so that is how you
nest up is extremely simple isn't it now
here are something else say I want to
create a tuple rep which has an element
Pythian but that element is repeated
five times so what you would generally
go for is type out PI sin Phi times but
thank God for Python there's a much
simpler way of doing this type it by sin
once and multiply this five times let's
print out rep now and as you see here
python exists within this double five
times one two three four five now maybe
this is not how you want to create your
tablet you want your tupple to just have
that one element Python initially but
later on while printing you decide you
know what I want Python to be printed
ten times within this double not a
problem
put your topple name here and then go
for it into ten and as you see here the
tupple has now ten elements within it so
guys remember when you're putting the
statement here it's not actually
modifying the tupple it's just printing
it this way so if I say left once again
and I run this this double just has one
element so next we look at slicing in
tuples so we created our topple num
previously I'll just print that out once
again so it has the elements one two
three four now suppose I want all the
elements from two up to the end of the
stubble to be printed in that case
what I do is I go for slicing where I
will mention my beginning and my ended
necks so my beginning index starting
from two is of course one and my end
index is basically the position four is
at or to the end of this double now when
I want all the elements up to the end I
do not need to mention my end index it's
by default taken so so if I just say
numb of one up til black run this your
top with sliced it gives out the
elements at the first second and third
position considering zeroth is our first
position of course now you can also
print this num topple in Reverse using
these indices so you seen num I leave my
start and end index empty give two
colons and then in the end I have minus
one so when you put this minus one here
so it basically prints out the reverse
of your topple let's check that out and
as you see your last element is now your
first element and your first element is
now your last element if you have any
doubts regarding how slicing works
please check out our video on Python
lists over there we have a detailed
description on how slicing is and there
will be no confusion since in case of
slicing at least tuples and lists are
exactly similar so let's look at the
string that I have here simply learn now
I want every letter of the string simply
learn to be an element of a tuple how do
I do this well pass the string as a
tuple so write tupple off and within
this you have your string which is again
within quotes right we'll run this
command and as you see here every
character is now a separate element in
our table so this procedure is called
unpacking now I'll just print out my num
couple once again so we can see what's
in it okay so I want to put these
elements which are inside a tuple into
various variables now in this case I
know that my topple has four elements so
I can have four variables a b c d and
i'll put this equal to num run this and
then I'll print out ABC and D so every
element of the tuple has gone into one
of these variables the first element
went into a second element into B and so
on
now what if we
no clue how many elements are there in
num in that case I could see a I want a
first element to go into my first
variable a no matter what and I want my
last element to go into this variable C
no matter what
now all the elements in between I'm not
very concerned about where they go so in
that case I can have another variable B
but this variable will be a list so the
star indicates that B is a list and then
this is equal to num we print out a B
and C so you see what happens here is my
first element went into a and my second
element went into C because these were
clearly indicated but every other
element in between went into my list B
so that is how unpacking works
so since tuples are immutable it's
impossible to delete the elements within
it but that does not mean you cannot
delete the tupple entirely so that is
what the del key word does we implement
this so I create a tuple couple one and
put some elements into it one two three
four now I'll use the del keyword now
I'll just print out this tuple so we
know it exists and what all elements are
within it so great are tuples created it
has the elements one two three four
within it
now I'll use Edel keyword to delete this
double so I say del space followed by
your topple name run this command now
let's try printing tuple 1 once again of
course since we did it all right
hopefully this tupple should not exist
and this should result in an error and
it is resulting in an error it's a
supple one is not defined so you can
completely delete the tupple if not
delete elements within the tupple so as
I mentioned previously most of the
methods that you have with lists does
not work with tuples because these
methods change the original list itself
but there are a few built-in functions
which do work with tuples they return
values or new lists and they do not have
any impact on the original tuples so it
works just fine we'll explore some of
these built-in functions I'll continue
using the tuple I created before that's
num so I'll create a new tuple num one
which has the elements three five say
four twos
six five eight and now we'll perform our
built-in function operations on this
number one tablet so the first one that
we look at is counting the number of
occurrences of a particular element so
that is the count function so you give
your topple name dot count off and the
element whose count you wanna know so I
want to know the number of two's in my
tuples number one run that and as you
see there are four twos now you can also
find the sum of all the elements within
your topple so that is sum of num1 you
just have your function some fast number
one to it now this sum function works
for tuples lists everything it's not a
function particularly for tuples or such
so the sum of all the elements within a
tuple is 35 and in a similar way you
also have the Len function which is in
fact even used for Strings so Len of
number one gives the number of elements
with a number which is nine we have nine
elements but remember our last index is
eight not nine our element is a two
coincidentally now we have the max
function for finding out the maximum
number in your topple so C a max of num1
which is eight and we also have a
function for checking the minimum of the
numbers within a tuple which is two in
this particular case so now listen
tupple i'm very similar in the sense of
what they hold so what if I have a list
say LST chose the elements one two three
four and I want to convert this list to
a table so we'll see how that is done
first I stored my list one two three
four so I'll just check the type of the
variable LST ensure that it's a list
which it is now we can convert this to a
tuple
so to convert this to a tuple enter your
variable name and then fast your list
name within these braces for the method
table run this code and now let's print
out TPL and as you see our list
LST has been converted to a tuple we can
also check its type so yeah a conversion
has worked out fine now this kind of a
situation of an arises when you put
certain elements into a list so you
create a list that you desire and then
you realize that you don't want this to
be changed at all throughout the program
so then you can convert the list to a
tuple you cannot convert a tuple to a
list though
so we previously saw how we can have
nested tuples that is tuples within
tuples now we can also have tuples
within lists so we'll check that out now
say I have a list LST and within this
list I will define my tuples so two of
the elements of my list LST will be
separate tuples I have a tuple 1 2 3 and
I'll have another tuple as the second
element of my list as 4 5 6 so I'll run
this code print out LST so LST is
created just fine it's a list which
holds two tuples now tuples are
immutable but lists are mutable so we
can add as many tuples as we want inside
this list so we can make modifications
to the list so I could say LS dot append
and to this I'll pass another list which
has three elements say couple inside
lists from this code now if I print out
list you'll see that he thought couple
has also been added to the list now we
can also remove tuples from the list
just use the remove function so LST dots
remove and within this I'll pass the
list that I want removed which is my
first list in this case so run that code
and print out the value of LST to check
what's in it right now
so our first list has been removed now
we just saw how you can nest tuples
within lists now we'll check out how we
can nest lists within tuples so I'll
create a tuple TPL and within this
couple I have two elements each of the
elements being a list so they have a b c
in my first list and d e f in my second
list run this and print out the value of
tuple before we proceed yeah so that's
our topple with two elements each
element a list now we cannot modify
tuples so initially when we had tuples
within list we could add more tuples to
that particular list but now we have
lists within tuples and we cannot add
more elements to this already defined
tuple but what we can do is we can
modify the list within the tuples so I
can
elements to the first element and the
second element of my object Taplin so
I'll try that out if I say supple zero
dot append so when I say topple zero its
accessing the first element of the
tupple and the first element of a tuple
is a list so to this I can use the
append function and I'll append an
element Z run this code and then check
out the elements within tupple and in
the similar manner we can also remove
elements from the list within the
stubble so I can say TPL of 0.2 move Z
and then print out TPL so you see Z has
been removed here now just for the sake
of it let's see what happens when we try
to add another list to this double so I
say TPL dot append and pass a list X Y Z
and then print out TPL so we get an
error because this time our object was a
tuple Nod lists and tuples cannot be
changed so with that we saw the many
concepts that is used with tupple along
with what Apple is we'll quickly now
have a very short exercise where we'll
recall some of the concepts that we
previously saw in this video so what is
this exercise that you're planning on
doing will initially create a tuple
which has the digits from 0 up to 9
called tuple 1 and then we create
another tupple by adding an element to
this tuple 1 so we are not adding an
element to topple 1 and modifying the
original tuple but we're creating an odd
the tupple using the elements in trouble
1 and adding another to it then we'll
create a tuple by adding the reverse of
topple 1 to this tuple so first we have
tupple 1 which has all the elements then
topple 2 which has all the elements of
tuple 1 plus another number and then we
have toppled 3 where we have all the
elements of topple 2 plus the reverse of
topple 1 so let's move on back to the
Jupiter notebook I'll create my tuple
which is called series 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 so that's my first tuple and I'll
print this out so tuples created next
thing we do is we create our second
tuple which is series 1 now see
this one will have all the elements of
series plus another element which is
stem so how can we add another element
to a tuple if you are using so how can
we add another element to this couple
without manually typing it out now as we
saw previously we can concatenate tuples
so we can say series 1 equal to series
and we'll add the second element as an
element of another tuple
so instead of just synched 10 which is
not possible because series is a tuple
and 10 is an integer we can say a couple
with just consists of 10 run this code
and print out series 1 so we have
successfully been able to add another
element to series and create another
couple series 1 now we have to create a
third tuple series 2 which will have all
the elements of series 1 plus the
reverse of series so again we're gonna
use concatenation to bring both these
tuples together say series 3 equal to
series and of course I can just say
series and plus but just for the sake of
recalling once again for how slicing
works so I'll put an 11 here and now to
that I'll add the reverse of CDs and not
series 1 so I'll just make this
correction in the previous one it's
supposed to be series 1 here and not
series and here I need to reverse it so
as we previously saw I'll put minus 1
here and leave the beginning and end
indexes empty run this and print out
series 3 so we have all elements of
series plus d-10 which makes up series 1
and then the reverse of series so with
this we come to an end of a Python
tutorials where we learned about what
tuples is if you have any doubts
regarding this please post them in the
comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you if you like
this video please hit the like button
also subscribe to our channel if you
have not yet as we have a lot more
videos coming up so keep learning see
y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here